Thema heute: Frauenquote!
Leute, wir sehen uns in den Kommentaren wieder!
Viele Männer sind empört: Warum wollen Frauen
die gleichen Rechte wie alle Menschen?
10.000e Jahre hat der Mann die Frau erfolgreich
unterdrückt, deswegen kommt die Forderung
der Frauen nach Gleichberechtigung für viele
Männer jetzt etwas plötzlich.
Hier mal kurz die krassesten Fakten:
- 69% der Bundestagsabgeordneten sind Männer.
- 80% der Experten im Fernsehen sind Männer.
- 92% aller Oberbürgermeister sind Männer.
Also hier aus meiner Perspektive sieht das
nach Gleichberechtigung aus.
Außerdem verdienen Frauen weniger und bekommen
nur die Hälfte der Rente.
Das erstaunliche ist: Frauen werden gar nicht
von Grund auf benachteiligt, sondern erst,
wenn es um Macht geht.
Gucken wir uns das mal vereinfacht an auf
einem Pavianfelsen:
Die Mehrheit aller Abiturienten und Studenten
sind Frauen, aber je höher man kommt in einer
Hierarchie, desto weniger Frauen gibt es.
Es ist nicht ausgeschlossen, dass Frauen an
die Spitze kommen, aber oben wird die Luft
dünn.
Warum ist das so?
Wissenschaftlicher Erkenntnisstand: Menschen
stellen die ein, die einem ähnlich sind.
Das muss keine aktive Diskriminierung sein,
es ist ein unbewusster Prozess: Bayern-Vorstände
stellen keine Dortmund-Anhänger ein, Männer selten Frauen.
Warum gibt es trotzdem noch Leute, die gegen
die Frauenquote sind?
Hä?
Gemeint ist: Weil die Frauenquote sichtbar
macht, dass Frauen benachteiligt werden, werden
Frauen umso mehr benachteiligt.
Wer das glaubt, sagt bei einem brennenden
Haus auch: Ich sollte die Bewohner nicht darauf
aufmerksam machen, dass ihr Haus brennt, nachher
fühlen sie sich als Brandopfer diskriminiert.
Die Frauenquote benachteiligt nicht die Männer,
sie beendet nur die Benachteiligung von Frauen.
88 % in deutschen DAX-Vorständen sind Männer.
2015 waren weniger Frauen in Mdax-Vorständen
als Männer mit den Namen Thomas und Andreas.
Vereinfacht gesagt sind also ganz oben in
der deutschen Wirtschaft 9 von 10 Pavianen
männlich.
Und das, obwohl auf dem Hügel viel mehr Weibchen
mitarbeiten.
Männerobergrenzen sind nicht nur deswegen
sinnvoll, weil kompetente Frauen endlich die
Positionen kriegen, die ihnen zustehen, sondern
auch, weil dadurch weniger inkompetente Männer
in Führungspositionen landen.
Und das stimmt!
Wenn Pavian-Männchen die ganze Zeit Pavian-Weibchen
vom Felsen schmeißen und die Pavianpolizei
eingreift, dann beschränkt es die Männchen
in ihrer Freiheit.
97 Prozent der befragten Unternehmen lehnen
eine gesetzliche Frauenquote ab.
Männer geführte Unternehmen, die gegen Frauenquoten
sind?
Mich hat's überrascht.
Ebenfalls überraschend fand ich, dass in
der Geschichte 100 Prozent aller Könige die
Einführung der Demokratie kritisch sahen.
Die Freiheit des Einen ist immer auch die
Einschränkung des Anderen.
Wenn ich in meiner Beziehung die Freiheit
habe, auszuschlafen, schränkt das meine Freundin
ein, weil sie dann nicht Schlagzeug üben
kann.
Wenn meine Freundin sich die Freiheit nimmt,
Schlagzeug zu üben, kann ich nicht ausschlafen.
Das war ein trauriges Beispiel, weil ich keine
Beziehung habe.
Immerhin kann ich ausschlafen.
Ich hab mir schonmal beim Aufstehen die Bänder
gerissen und musste danach an Krücken laufen.
Krücken sind scheiße.
Aber im Vergleich zum Umfallen, sind Krücken
cool.
Die Frauenquote macht keinen Spaß.
Aber wenn Frauen dadurch die Macht bekommen,
die ihnen zusteht, sollte man sie überall
einführen.
Einfach aus Liebe.